by Fox News contributor Sarah Carter in
the Hills John Solomon each out with
brand new reports detailing the ongoing
allegations in the House and the Senate
as to whether the FBI agent remember
Peters truck and other FBI employees may
have been responsible for media leaks
surrounding the Russia investigation
joining us to break it all down are the
hills John Solomon Fox News contributor
Sarah Carter and along with us the
author of the bestseller trumped up
Harvard Law Professor Alan Dershowitz is
with us all right let's get to the
details John we'll we'll start with you
basically they are admitting when they
talk about oh they have advanced
knowledge of this thing oh the article
is out but hidden behind a paywall and
then it gets you know goes through a
whole the whole tone is an T Bureau just
the tiny bit from Us page replies
there's more red in the CF article I
mean are they not referencing they are
leaking to the press and what does that
mean how profound is that I don't think
we know entirely but congressional
investigators certainly have a strong
suspicion that these text messages point
to an operation inside the FBI that was
leaking information
spinning reporters tracking down
reporters there's a whole effort where
the two of them are trying to track down
the great reporter from the New York
Times Matt Apuzzo and why else would
they be trying to track down a reporter
unless someone wanted to talk to him but
I walked away well I read through
hundreds of these messages over the week
I walked away from one thing I remember
the moment when James Comey and his
testimony said FBI agents don't give a
rip about politics and they don't leak
after you read these messages you go out
the way thinking these two FBI agents
cared a lot about politics and they were
monitoring the media almost like they
were a press office I keep hearing sir
Sarah that we're going to learn a lot
more about a connection between some
people within the intelligence community
and the CIA and elsewhere about their
relationships with the media but my more
specific question for the moment
has to do with I think one of the worst
parts of this is they're looking up the
names of the family the kids of a
particular New York Times reporter what
because they don't like is reporting
well we don't know do we we these these
are the questions that the committee
members want to have answered and that's
why they want to interview struck they
wanted
interview lisa page and remember this is
just what we've been looking at these
text messages between the two of them
but you also have general counsel James
Baker who they want to question in
Andrew Weissman who's over at the DOJ
what about Paige advising McCabe exactly
Paige advising McCain and all of the
questions that they have regarding the
you know the insurance policy with
McCabe so they're gonna want to question
Andrew McCabe the deputy director this
is only we're gonna be leaving in March
a few hundred texts and it's going to be
slow released to these agents to these
the House and Senate committees five
hundred ninety five hundred but they're
expected to receive all of those very
soon they won't be slowed ruled out
we're expecting a lot by January 11 you
see this type of leaking I have followed
your comments on this very very closely
and then you see that the Trump Russia
collusion narrative is really dying and
withering on a line now they've moved
into a collective media bubble that oh
this president what we got to go to the
25th amendment what is your reaction to
all of it 25th amendment is totally
irrelevant to what's going on it was
designed for somebody who had a stroke
or was involved in a serious accident
and was incapacitated it requires the
vice president the cabinet two-thirds of
each house of Congress it's a fool's
errand it's not going to happen about it
of course it's not gonna happen but what
they're trying to do though is now that
they couldn't criminalize political
differences they're trying to have to
live to psychiatry's political
differences they're trying to say oh
maybe we can't get him on crime but
we're gonna show that he has mental
problems that he's disturbed a guy on
CNN today was talking about he has
Alzheimer's he should be subjected to
what NBC the same exam that is so
dangerous that's what they did in the
former Soviet Union I was involved
representing some dissidents in the
Soviet Union who was sent to mental
hospitals they did that in China they
did that in apartheid South and you know
Nathan or Solzhenitsyn there was agony
she gave that big speech what they might
have better hormones at Harvard I was
there right it was a guy named Roy
Medvedev who wrote a book about being
committed to a psychiatric cost
at all but it was a pervasive way that
tyrannical governments use the power of
psychiatry to try to not answer the
merits we don't want to debate the
merits
he's crazy Soviet was notorious for this
what we're doing all the time in the
American Psychiatric Association sent a
delegation and the American Psychiatric
Association at the Goldwater case said
it is wrong for any psychiatrist ever to
diagnose anybody without them examining
them look I took Lorne psychiatry for 25
years at Harvard I coat my coat
if edited the textbook on law and
psychiatry and the first rule of
psychiatry is you do not diagnose based
on political funny you say based on read
the book the synthesis of Russian
mind-control techniques is everything
you are discussing it's all true every
bit of it danger so danger don't like
somebody vote against them exact I've
voted against Donald Trump I noted
figure Larry Clinton by the way but it's
the only thing we disagree on this tease
but I'm doing it not from a political
you're doing it from a constitutional
law professor effective and and the
threat to the Constitution is a clear
and present danger it's let me let me
bring John and Sarah back and Sarah you
add to that you know when you start
surveilling unmasking you don't minimize
and then you leak raw intelligence they
did that to general Flynn and then I'm
sure I will bet everything they have
that they said oh you either agree that
you lied to us or we're going after your
sellers oh of course they did of course
that's and that is definitely what I'm
hearing from my sources I mean right now
Sean there are 27 leak investigations at
the Department of Justice that's triple
what they had over the last three years
so 27 leak investigations one of those I
guarantee you is general Flynn the leak
the classified leak between general
Flynn it talks about a conversation with
Keyes farm there it was a it was a major
crime and and we're looking at those
leaks and we're also looking at the
inspector general right now we're
waiting on that inspector it's only a
crime if it's leaking grand jury minutes
not just leaking is a violation of their
rules but it's not itself a crime look
leaking has been a weapon
of prosecutors for years I've had
prosecutors tell me implicitly
if you don't plead your client guilty
you will be shocked at what will come
out about death by a thousand cuts isn't
a path exactly right and I'm against it
whether it's leaking against Hillary
Clinton over their anger against Donald
Trump it's wrong you don't leak John
Solomon we only have a small percentage
of these I don't think Wow
if we only have hundreds and there's
thousands what's next yeah I think the
question is who's gonna follow this
breadcrumb trail somebody let a
breadcrumb trail to create the Russian
narrative we got to get to the bottom of
it great work thank you